han pasado 33 años desde aquel día en
que los habitantes de álava fueron
masacrados la población de esta
localidad kurdo iraquí fue atacada con
agentes químicos un asalto desde el
cielo por parte de las fuerzas del ex
dictador iraquí saddam hussein- se
estima que unas 5 mil personas murieron
hoy para muchos sobrevivientes se trata
de una muerte en vida a raíz de la
inhalación de los gases letales ahora
sufren de enfermedades congénitas cáncer
e incluso los recién nacidos traen
complicaciones y deformaciones en el
cuerpo hawker saber tenía apenas tres
años cuando ocurrió el ataque debe usar
un respirador 20 horas al día para poder
vivir y mi salud depende de esta máquina
y de un tratamiento duermo respirando a
través de este dispositivo
mi estado de salud es muy malo no solo
yo hay más de 25 personas así mi vida es
muy dura
algunas de las víctimas recibieron
tratamiento en europa pagado por las
autoridades kurdas pero otros no han
podido viajar a raíz
la lucha contra el autoproclamado estado
islámico y las condiciones de salud de
las personas afectadas no son buenas no
hay seguimiento y no existe un programa
para atenderlas por lo que sus
condiciones de salud se están empeorando
lamentablemente
estos se acercan más de 30 años después
del bombardeo sus tratamientos siguen
siendo escasos estiba oxígeno festival
el ataque al marco la culminación de una
despiadada campaña de represalias por
parte de hussein contra quienes se
consideraban del lado de irán cuando el
devastador conflicto entre los dos
vecinos que duró ocho años llegaba a su
fin hasta el día de hoy aún quedan
residuos del gas que se esparció por la
ciudad e incluso se pueden encontrar
proyectiles sin detonar bajo los
cimientos de edificios recién
construidos